[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 29 novembre à
réfléchir aux enjeux de l'agriculture
dans la plaine de versailles principe
d'une réunion publique organisée hier à
saint nom la bretèche
trois tables rondes ont animé la soirée
à l'initiative de deux député des
yvelines
une manière de conclure les états
généraux de l'alimentation au niveau
local il vient d'être réélu à la
présidence du modem 78 le député de la
9e circonscription du département bruno
myle yen est notre invité avec lui nous
parlons de son nouveau mandat de trois
ans à la tête du mouvement démocrate des
yvelines et de l'actualité politique
et puis magny-les-hameaux organise sa
semaine de la citoyenneté cinq jours à
destination des jeunes de la commune
pour mieux comprendre le fonctionnement
des institutions françaises
hier un rallye citoyen se dérouler au
sein de l'hôtel de ville nous étions sur
place une grande consultation nationale
initiée par le ministère de
l'agriculture les états généraux de
l'alimentation se termine
ils ont donné la parole aux agriculteurs
pour évoquer la création de grandes
filières de production au niveau local
cet événement s'est conclue hier par une
réunion publique à saint nom la bretèche
à la à l'initiative de député des
yvelines elle questionné sur les enjeux
de l'agriculture dans la plaine de
versailles un sujet de nicolas
kirillovitch bien loin des polémiques
européenne sur le glyphosate localement
habitants élus associations et
agriculteurs de la plaine de versailles
planchent sur les enjeux agricoles de
leur territoire un territoire prisé avec
douze nouvelles exploitations qui se
sont installés récemment un record en
ile-de-france qu'il est nécessaire de
préserver ce que représente la plaine de
versailles
est un
un système de biodiversité dans tous les
sens du terme et que pour qu'on puisse
avoir une nourriture de qualité il faut
que les acteurs c'est-à-dire les
agricultures mais aussi les
consommateurs jouent le jeu
comment favoriser la consommation locale
comment produire de façon responsable et
satisfaire la demande des consommateurs
la soirée s'est déroulée autour de trois
tables rondes et a permis de soulever de
nombreuses problématiques autour du
modèle agricole actuel
l'objectif est en fait de réussir à
montrer que le cahier des charges en
agriculture française est vertueux sain
et assure vraiment un gage de fiabilité
et de et de sécurité alimentaire
organisée par deux députés de la
république en marche cette réunion
publique s'inscrit dans le cadre des
états généraux de l'alimentation lancé
il ya quatre mois partout en france
objectif rapprocher l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière
ce qui m'a vraiment motivé aujourd'hui
c'est de voir
ce renouveau dans l'agriculture ces
jeunes agriculteurs qui s'investissent
ce qui m'a plu aussi c'est de voir qu'il
y avait juste des consommateurs qui sont
venus aujourd'hui qui sont en demande
qui sont en attente d'une solution sur
des circuits courts qui ont besoin
d'informations sans calendrier fixe pour
le moment les états généraux de
l'alimentation devrait déboucher sur un
projet de loi dès le premier semestre
2010 8 dans l'actualité visite
officielle cet après midi la secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
sophie cluzel s'est rendu à versailles
elle est venue ouvrir les 22e journée à
d'études de recherches et de formation
au palais des congrès un événement en
présence de plus de 900 professionnels
sur trois jours objectif notamment aider
les jeunes avec troubles du comportement
à mieux vivre au quotidien
c'est organisé par l'association air
déplacement suivi par camille lambert
je pense qu'il faut tout à fait
reconnaître la valeur de tous les
travaux qui ont été depuis des années
porté par parlait par l'association lève
pour rénover justement une réponse pour
qu'elle soit vraiment une réponse
accompagner pour tous ces jeunes qui
présentent des troubles qui sont
difficiles
justement un pouvoir rester dans un
circuit ordinaire sans être accompagnée
donc je pense qu'ils ont une valeur
colossale pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de ces jeunes nous avons décidé
cette année de placer ces journées
d'étude sous le signe de la pluralité et
de la nouveauté
que se passe-t-il dans notre
environnement comment la politique de la
santé mentale se réorganisait les
commentaires affluent sur nos
établissements elle accompagne le
président de la république la députée
l'héroîne des yvelines marie le bec
participe à la tournée africaine
d'emmanuel macron un voyage au burkina
faso en côte d'ivoire c'est aujourd'hui
et puis au ghana pour finir la
parlementaire qui président à
l'assemblée nationale le groupe d'amitié
france côte d'ivoire et nous reviendrons
sur ce déplacement présidentiel dans
notre édition de demain jeudi avec
l'association des ressortissants
africains de saint quentin en yvelines
est lui aussi est député des yvelines
bruno milian bonsoir soit vous êtes vous
d'être réélu à la tête du modem soixante
dix huit pour un mandat de trois cents
dans trois ans on en parle dans un
instant une réaction peut être déjà sur
le voyage des manuels macron en afrique
premier discours hier devant les
étudiants de l'université de ouagadougou
au burkina faso
sur la forme on sent un style
dépoussiérer il a donné la parole à des
étudiants dont les questions semble-t-il
n'était pas filtré donc ils ont pu poser
leurs questions sans fil tropez dans la
république vous voyez bien que c'est
dans le style de notre président
emmanuel macron il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
eu de grosse surprise par rapport à ça
c'est un style assez
effectivement je n'irais pas jusqu'à
dire décontracté mais en tout cas direct
et moi ce que j'ai retenu surtout c'est
qu'on vient de tourner une page il a
tourné nous vient de tourner la page de
la sq ont appelé la centrafrique où la
france se croyait encore m mettre des
manettes en afrique noire comme du temps
de la colonie alors il n'est pas
question de se présenter il n'est pas
question de se flageller m'aidait pas
question non plus d'en lever nos
responsabilités sur ce qui s'est passé
et surtout on est là maintenant
effectivement pour leur tendre la main
et pour les aider sans leur imposer nos
choix
c'est ça qu'un autre actualité aussi le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
rencontré aujourd'hui les chefs des
principaux partis français dont françois
bayrou pour le modem
ils les informer du projet de loi qui
changera le mode de scrutin aux
européennes en 2018 exit les huit
circonscriptions françaises pour un
retour à une seule circonscription
nature est et du sindh réforme qui est
nécessaire je sais pas si elle est
nécessaire mais en tout cas je pense que
pour les débats et pour l'europe pour ce
qu'on veut faire de l'europe demain
je pense que les listes nationales sont
sont plus intéressante parce qu'on va
avoir des débats du coup sur le fond et
pas des débats qui vont et étriqué comme
ça a été lors des dernières lors des
dernières élections et on va remettre un
petit peu l'europe au centre de nos
préoccupations et la reconstruction
européenne et est très très très
importante pour les années qui viennent
autant que la reconstruction dire
évidemment de notre pays mais les deux
vont de pair prochaines élections
européennes en 2010 l'a fait non 2018
comme je les aime et de l'es19
alors bruno myle yens vous avez été
réélu ce mois-ci président du modem 78
dans un grand suspense
non en réalité vous étiez le seul
candidat à votre propre succession réélu
à 97 4% des voix
pourquoi repartir pour un nouveau mandat
en mandat de trois ans ben parce que
parce que la donne un tout petit peu
changé on a beaucoup travaillé les trois
précédentes années et là je veux
remercier toute l'équipe du bureau
départemental et les conseillers
départementaux parce qu'il ya un gros
boulot qui a été fait sur le département
on est devenus quand même on va la voir
un tout petit peu plus visible
et puis aujourd'hui nous sommes quand
même un des deux partis de la majorité
présidentielle
même si on est moins nombreux que la lrm
on est présent à l'assemblée on
travaille avec les cabinets ministériels
donc ça nous donne des opportunités
d'agir sur le territoire qui sont quand
même plus importante que quand on est
juste en alliance ou dans une opposition
là on a un peu plus de cartes en main il
reste encore beaucoup de choses à faire
il faut qu'on aille vraiment vers nos
citoyens nous on veut imposer au niveau
territorial une politique qui soit
vraiment une politique territoriale du
citoyen portait sur le projet et pas
dans la guerre des dans la guerre des
chapelles parce que ça nous intéresse
pas donc le boulot ça va être de
construire justement de continuer à
construire ce qu'on recommence à
construire avec la république en marche
c'est à dire un axe central qui aille au
delà de nos deux parties et qui puisse
intéresser les gens de bonne volonté qui
veulent travailler sur des projets
concrets dans l'intérêt général et pas
seulement pour rester dans l'autre soit
comme ça a été pendant des années le cas
dans pas mal de départements journée
dans les yvelines mais c'est valable un
petit peu partout quand vous êtes député
conseiller
régional d'île de france également
président de natureparif quelle agence
pour la nature et la biodiversité vous
avez encore le temps de vous consacrer
au modem 78 à la fédération à des jeux
vous faire je suis très très épaulé au
modem 70 notamment par mon délégué
départemental jean baptiste à monique
entre autres mais l'équipe est vraiment
soudée resserré il y avait un sens de
faire ça parce qu'il ya des là il ya des
axes politiques forts à donner et puis
on verra un j'irai pas au delà un je
vous dis je ferai deux mandats mais ça
sera votre dernier dont 1,9 sur la tête
le jam des yvelines alors quelles sont
les perspectives
on voulait dit le modem est un allié la
république en marche ça c'était pour les
présidentielles aussi pour les
législatives d'ailleurs vous faites
partie donc du coût de ce groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale il ya deux membre
aussi du modem qui sont au gouvernement
jacqueline gourault et geneviève
darrieussecq il faut compter sur sur le
modem pour les prochaines échéances
électorales
ben écoute j'espère qu'on va compter sur
nous en tout cas nous on va continuer à
porter le projet présidentiel parce que
la façon dont ça se fait nous nous
convient c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant elle a été habituée à un état
une administration qui décide d'en haut
et qui transmet cette décision d'en haut
ou vers le bas donc s'aperçoit de 40 ans
que ça fonctionne pas enfin fallait pas
être non plus grand clerc pour ne pas
comprendre que ça ne fonctionnerait pas
hélas ce que j'apprécie dans l'action
qui est en train d'être mené au delà de
toute polémique qu'on peut avoir sur les
choix qui sont faits par le gouvernement
et par le président de la république
c'est que il y à un dialogue permanent
entre les cabinets ministériels et
notamment les députés à l'assemblée
nationale il ya besoin de faire remonter
les infos du terrain pour ajuster
justement les politiques maintenant
presque gouvernement et je pense que
c'est la bonne méthode
vous parliez des
un sujet là j'ai vu les les états
généraux l'alimentation c'en est un
exemple mais il y en a plein d'autres
qui les assises de la mobilité
voilà c'est une façon de fonctionner moi
qui me convient parce que on tient
compte de la vie du citoyen et ça c'est
très important pour reconstruire le pays
comptait sur moi même des les
européennes en 2019 ah bah de toute
façon il y aura il y aura un après je
sais pas comment ce resort ont fait les
listes mais j'imagine quand même que on
va partir en alliance avec avec la
république en marche pour les
européennes puisque toute façon là pour
le coup on est à peu près d'accord sur
tout ce sont deux parties qui sont très
europhile et il n'y a aucune raison
qu'on parte pas ensemble merci bruno
milian d'avoir été avec nous je vous en
prie député modem de la 9e
circonscription des yvelines et où
venait d'être réélu à la tête du
mouvement démocrate dans le département
ça a été inauguré ce matin le centre
commercial parly 2 au chesnay compte une
nouvelle extension un passage qui permet
aux clients de circuler plus facilement
au sein de l'enceinte pour le moment
pour le moment de nouveaux parkings 16
boutiques qui ouvrait à des enseignes
historiques du centre qui se réinvente
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude important puisqu'elle souligner
la fin de 24 mois de travaux pour le
magasin et de vingt mois de travaux pour
le centre qui nous entoure et bien sûr
c'est avec impatience et même un peu
d'émotion qu'on va vivre cette journée
de réouverture et d'inauguration du
centre
il est vraiment un élément partenaires
de la commune c'est un centre dans la
ville
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
passé des centaines voire des milliers
d'heures depuis plus de dix ans pour
aboutir à ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui
et je vous disais pour le moment puisque
la rénovation globale de parly 2 a
débuté puis 2010 201 millions d'euros
ont été investis et le dernier chantier
en cours c'est la construction du
multiplexe pour une ouverture prévue en
elle nous vous en parlions hier dans le
7-8 journal magny les hameaux organise
sa semaine de la citoyenneté événements
qui se déroulent depuis plusieurs années
à destination des écoliers et collégiens
de la commune plusieurs rendez vous au
programme et notamment un rallye citoyen
qui faisait étape il hier à l'hôtel de
ville
de magny les hameaux reportage mélanie
poker c'est pas un tribunal
difficile pour ces élèves de 5e du
collège albert einstein de deviner où il
se trouve
christine mercier première adjointe de
la mairie leur fait découvrir le conseil
municipal
c'est important qu'ils sachent ce qu'il
ya dans leur commune mais surtout
comment ça fonctionne et leur montrer
que ça fonctionne de la même manière
partout et c'est important c'est ça fait
partie de la citoyenneté 30 minutes des
changes pour apprendre qu'il ya 29
conseillers municipaux dont huit
adjoints au maire durant une semaine les
citoyens de demain vont à la rencontre
des acteurs de la commune de quoi
peut-être susciter des vocations
il y avait quelque chose que je lis déjà
mais la plupart non c'est plus tard on
aimerait bien pas faire le même métier
ou postuler bas au moins on sait à peu
près les bases je savais pas qu'on
pouvait assister aux réunions
or vote et que
il y avait beaucoup de
deux fonctionnaires qui travaillent ici
la semaine de la citoyenneté concerne
tous les élèves du cp au collège
un temps fort devrait rassembler tous
les acteurs en avril 2018 à plaisir le
projet de réaménagement du centre ville
suit son cours avec des concertations
auprès des habitants lundi soir se
tenait une dernière réunion publique à
la mairie
elle a servi à faire le point sur les
différentes idées évoquées et les pistes
envisagées camille lambert
c'est un projet d'envergure auquel se
préparent la ville de plaisir la
requalification de son centre ville
trois secteurs sont particulièrement
concernés le quartier du val hibou la
zone de l'hôpital charcot et le centre
historique
une évolution conséquente pour les
plaisirs oies et c'est justement avec
eux que la mairie souhaite travailler
elle a organisé trois réunions publiques
destinées aux habitants
moi je suis plus intéressé par la
refonte les le projet du centre ville
sur le site de l'hôpital charcot donc
comme j'habite juste en face donc je
serai aux premières loges donc s'il ya
des maisons des immeubles qui vont être
construits ça m'intéresse au plus haut
point à savoir jusqu'où cet aménagement
va aller au niveau de cette ville
comment ça va se passer des
interrogations nombreuses même si
l'heure est toujours à la concertation
que croit car encore des personnes qui
pensent que ce sont déjà des résultats
et des décisions que nous avons prises
alors que non nous ne sommes que dans
une phase diagnostic
on est dans une dans une discussion dans
un échange plus justement
imaginez ce qu'on pourrait faire 6 sur
la ville il y avait des choses qui
allaient se libérer
parce que la fusion des deux hôpitaux
fait qu' il y a beaucoup de foncier qui
se libèrent actuellement et on va pas
laisser faire n'importe quoi parmi les
pistes évoquées
l'aménagement du ru le prolongement
d'une coulée verte et la création de
liaisons douces
concernant le vélib ou la réhabilitation
a déjà commencé pour casser
d'enfermement du quartier de la ville
prévoit de nouveaux cheminements et la
création d'une place avec différents
commerces
il ya plusieurs coulées vertes il ya
plusieurs il ya la coulée bleus et puis
il ya également toute cette installation
des pistes cyclables que nous souhaitons
mettre d'agrandir les trottoirs et puis
aussi de remettre et de repositionner
les commerces de proximité on a la
chance d'avoir une zone commerciale très
intense mais il faut aussi que l'on
maintienne et qu'on leur développe tout
cet espace qui est l'espace des
commerces de proximité
favoriser les petits commerces une
demande des habitants
elle concerne également le centre
historique un projet important qui
devrait se concrétiser d'ici 20 à 25 ans
les plaisirs oies sont toujours invités
à laisser leurs avis et leurs questions
sur le site plaisir de nos points comme
un développement qui peine à se
concrétiser le déploiement de la fibre
optique sfr est jugé trop lent par les
instances de l'agglomération un courrier
a été envoyé récemment à l'opérateur
d'après saint quentin en yvelines
aucun planning précis sur la
modernisation du réseau n'a été définie
depuis la réunion publique que vous
voyez à l'image à l'agglomération qui
indique travailler actuellement avec la
concurrence pour une nouvelle offre de
très haut débit dans les prochains mois
suite de notre série de reportages sur
le fait main dans les yvelines ce soit
rencontre avec un maître voilier
installé à coignières à valérie et viale
répare ses voiles dans son atelier à
côté de cette activité de réparation
elle recycle également ses voiles et
créer des accessoires nicolas landry et
les arrêts ch
donc là j'ai un client qui m'a apporté
un bain génois génois c'est la plus
grande voile qui assure un bateau à près
de 200 kilomètres des côtes normandes
valérie vial garde un oeil sur l'anr
dans son atelier à coignières cette
maître voilier travail est réparé tous
les types de voile depuis quelques
années on voit apparaître des voiles en
carbone dévoile enfin tex et des laminés
donc là ça se casse beaucoup plus
facilement
et là on les répare beaucoup beaucoup
plus il ya des filles qui sont
particulier si les fibres avec un petit
peu de paraffine dessus c'est à dire que
quand on coud me chauffe ça fait faire
fondre la paraffine et ça bouge tous les
trous sera convient qu'une voilà les
étanche
valérie vielle commence sa formation à
17 ans dans une voilerie à ouistreham en
normandie
elle débarque ensuite à saint quentin en
yvelines j'ai commencé à arriver ici
j'ai travaillé pour nos de voilerie tête
à saint cyr l'école
et puis après j'ai travaillé pour la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines pendant 18 ans en tant que
maître voilier j'ai créé mon post sur la
base de loisirs et puis maintenant ça
fait sept ans que j'ai créé ma propre
entreprise en région parisienne comme il
ya beaucoup de gens qui naviguent ça
soit en planche à voile ou en kitesurf
ou en bateau ça navigue quand même pas
mal
donc j'ai un petit peu de clients c'est
régulier 32 ans d'activités pour cette
normande de coeur et les voiles n'ont
quasiment plus de secret pour elle
elle passe tout entre ses mains comme le
spi le génois ou encore la grande voile
sa machine à coudre pour acolytes
valérie développe au fil des ans un côté
artistique
j'étais beaucoup plus créatrices que
couturière donc du coup j'ai toujours
créé plein de choses toujours des sacs
donc je recycle est énormément les
voiles de bateau tout ce que je pouvais
recycle et se recycle et en pochette en
sac en pouffant table son imagination
débordante et éco-responsable l'amène à
créer plusieurs objets originaux
réalisés exclusivement à partir de
voiles recyclées
donc ça peut être des fois le très
vieille c'est à dire que les voiles au
début elle était en coton comme celle ci
c'est une voile qui vient de l'est
loctudy qui en rouge parce qu'on faisait
beaucoup de rouge à l'époque et du tan
tan c'est le marron foncé autrement
voilà notre 6e récupère même les
vieilles râle un ghetto je dessine
d'abord mon sac et puis après 20 par
rapport à la voile il faut regarder si
la voilà encore bonne donc on la met à
laver dans la machine à laver
et puis on voit ce qui reste et puis
après on coupe ses morceaux en fonction
de ce qu'on veut comme modèle tout
simplement
après vous avez tous qui planche à voile
alors c'est des couleurs un peu flashy
parce que les années 70 80 c'était que
des couleurs qu'on voit bien sur l'eau
de très très loin la confection d'un
accessoire représente pas loin de 20
heures de travail pour valérie qui en
vrai passionné n'a de cesse d'innover sa
spécialité le vent peut souffler fort
sur coignières les voiles sont
accessibles à tous il expose ses oeuvres
à la verrière bonsoir amis de fakhoury
bonsoir artistes peintres et sculpteurs
vous êtes originaire de laterrière et
vous a proposé en oeuvre c'est le nom
de votre exposition à voir à partir de
demain au centre socio culturel espace
jacques miquel donc à la derrière le
vernissage ses deux mains à 18h première
question pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas votre style le style amène à vide
fakhoury c'est quoi en fait c'est plus
c'est le sépare beau mystère un mystère
il s'applique pictures à lyster pictural
en mystère voire des en fait à peinture
c'est un moyen d'expression pour vous
c'est l'un des envois on voit quelques
années on voit quelques oeuvres à
l'image ouais vous le dit
mystère on le ressent comme quelque
chose d'abstrait finalement c'est ça
ouais c'est très abstrait ya aucune
figuration dans ses tableaux et qu'elles
sont donc là on voit des peintures à
l'image vous avez plusieurs supports de
travail à de la peinture mais y'a pas
que c'est le cas il ya quelques objets
des petites sculptures que j'ai en fait
d assemblage comme là on peut voir un
hommage à saint-exupéry
ça fait combien de temps que vous vous
exercer dans l'art en fait j'ai commencé
en 1981 j'ai perdu mes premières heures
je prendrai à peu près de trois heures
par an aujourd'hui la en 2017 je
comptabilise 140 vente en fait peintures
et sculptures confondues donc tout ça
c'est une manière oui totalement
professionnel c'est vraiment votre
profession vous est consacré à 100 % à
100 %
et qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie à la
base si on revient sur votre parcours de
vous exprimer dans l'art on voyait des
peintres qui les choses et les teintures
prestigieuse
on ne sait pas trop new yorkais à paris
les années 80 c'était assez foisonnant
j'en ai envie de leur ressembler c'est
dur de se lancer au début 2011 on est on
est convaincu qu'il faut faire ça qu'il
fallait faire ça si voilà on est
convaincu on est convaincus de ce
parcours il faut pas il faut travailler
alors on vous dit vous n'êtes pas un
troquet mais vous travaillez vous
évoquiez les artistes new-yorkais du
coup quelles sont vos inspirations
artistes que j'aime particulièrement
c'est james brown
mais qu'on ne voit pas on voit plus cet
artiste et contenant 10 pas
mais c'est un très grand artiste
d'exposer au salon de mars sur le champ
de mars dans les années 80 c'est un
artiste new yorkais c'est lui qui vous a
donné à la base l'envi de commencer
c'est ça parce que c'était des choses
c'est de la peinture précieuse était
cultivé c'était magnifique
et côté français ce qu'il ya des
inspirations en fait oui j'aime beaucoup
les pins en français j'aime les peintres
marocains du maghreb des années 50
j'avais plus dans vos oeuvres et ce
qu'on peut ressentir alors vous disiez
c'est c'est autour du mystère mais est
ce qu'il ya un message que voulait faire
passer vous dans vos oeuvres
pas forcément un message mais en tout
cas il n'est pas sûr qu'ils puissent
décoré et décoratives quoi c'est d'abord
le sait le premier rôle de votre art
c'est quelque chose de décoratif ou à
découvrir si si mais on se plonge dans
la peinture on réfléchit on se déplace
on voit des teintes très bleuté très
très violette c'est vous travaillez sur
sur ses couleurs il ya plusieurs
couleurs là en l'occurrence pour
l'exposition c'est vrai que on le voit
l'image beaucoup de teintes bleutées et
violette voit en fait la peinture bleue
et le gfc très spirituel des couleurs
spirituel et pourquoi justement c'est
qu'est-ce que vous pourquoi vous avez
l'impression de spiritualité autour de
ses couleurs bah déjà regardé si je
voyais bien les couleurs mauves elles
sont elles sont elles sont plutôt ses
pas il faut forcément une couleur de
deuil mais en tout cas une une couleur
de profondes qui colore de profondeur
une couleur de bas aussi deux mystères
là on revient pour le coup au mystère
c'est ça du coup la source est pour
cette exposition c'est un ensemble de
vos oeuvres c'est une période précise de
travail dans votre dans votre carrière
ou c'est un ensemble
le monde en face à l'ensemble qui que
j'ai commencé à peindre
il ya au mois de mars à peu près j'ai
commencé en mars le maire de la verrière
madame du tu as eu cette idée d'exclure
faire une exposition d'accord donc c'est
une exposition enfin ses oeuvres que
l'on voit à l'exposition ont été
préparés spécialement pour cette
exposition pour sa très bien et dernière
enfin d'autres d'autres questions mais
vous vous espérez les vendre ses oeuvres
ou c'est juste pour donner envie
quel est le but recherché ça peut donner
envie des gens de pain de même de
travailler pour c'est la faute aux coups
de feu mais ouais c'est ça pour les
vendre je m'adresse à des acquéreurs et
collectionneurs des amateurs qui vient
de revoir l'exposition et qui peut-être
acquerront une oeuvre pour partager ce
rêve de profondeur et de mystère et ce
mystère cette profondeur elle est à voir
jusqu'au 30 décembre ses savantes et un
des 31 décembre donc jusqu'au dernier
jour de cette année 2010 cet essai au
centre socio culturel espace jacques
miquel à la verrière merci à vis de
favori d'avoir été avec nous je remercie
le rappel artistes peintres et
sculpteurs et vous exposez donc à la
verrière jusqu'au 31 décembre plus
d'informations sur le site de la
verrière qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avant de se quitter attention quelques
flocons pourraient tomber demain sur
saint quentin en yvelines pas assez a
priori pour faire un bonhomme de neige
en revanche vous pouvez être prévenu par
sms du déclenchement des opérations de
salage et de déneigement sur les voies
intercommunale inscription gratuite sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de l'avoir suivi ripley et reportages à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 60,18 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]